las explosiones de dinamita y la disputa
entre cocaleros rivales por el control
del mercado de la coca de la paz están
causando miedo y caos pero su uso se ha
vuelto rutinario en el conflicto
poniendo en riesgo la vida de los
propios manifestantes
tras una explosión ocurrida en una
protesta el pasado mes de agosto el
cocalero plácido cota resultó gravemente
herido y aunque logró quedar con vida
perdió su brazo izquierdo
agradecerán
una segunda vez
la policía ha detenido a manifestantes
del bando cocalero antigubernamental por
tener explosivos sin embargo los dos
sectores enfrentados los han usado para
atacarse causando varios lesionados los
contrarios al gobierno aseguran que se
defienden de la represión
lo usan para defenderse porque no tienen
otro argumento cuando ya son rebasados
no son escuchados la policía también
suprime a la protesta con explosivos
nació en las rebeliones mineras contra
las dictaduras militares o un legislador
minero pidió al parlamento que la
dinamita sea declarada patrimonio
cultural del país pero la propuesta fue
vetada el senador que frenó la idea
advierte sobre una ambigüedad en el
gobierno cuando el movimiento social un
grupo es afín al gobierno meta dinamita
cuando el grupo es contrario como el
caso de adepcoca la dinamita según un
conflicto social o de posible daño a la
sociedad
el barrio de la paz que se ha convertido
en el campo de batalla de los dos bandos
pide paz mientras tanto los vecinos han
construido barricadas en sus calles para
protegerse